the only way to be truly satisfied is to
do what you believe is great work and
the only way to do great work is to love
what you do if you haven't found it yet
keep looking and don't settle as with
all matters of the heart you'll know
when you find it sometimes life's gonna
hit you in the head with a brick don't
lose faith I'm convinced that the only
thing that kept me going was that I
loved what I did you've got to find what
you love so you have to trust that the
dots will somehow connect in your future
you have to trust in something your gut
destiny life karma whatever because
believing that the dots will connect
down the road will give you the
confidence to follow your heart even
when it leads you off the well-worn path
and that will make all the difference
your time is limited so don't waste it
living someone else's life don't be
trapped by Dogma which is living with
the results of other people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drown out your own inner voice and most
important have the courage to follow
your heart and intuition they somehow
already know what you truly want to
become everything else is secondary